alternativ hätte man ihm gerade gesagt
dass er wegen steuerhinterziehung
angeklagt wird checken die ersten bilder
von youtube und deshalb nehme ich ganz
paket das heißt check-ins david checken
die ausstrahlung die tschechen die
qualität der bilder die solche damals
hatten und gucken wie sich so entwickelt
bei der ganzen sache rum mit lukas der
müssen wir mit luca hat er am sechsten
august 2013 dieses bild gefordert
darauf weist die gute halten dass die
qualität der innen kameras damals
einfach nicht so gut war das bild ist
natürlich ziemlich verschwommen nur vom
autor geht man sieht aber angesicht
richtig klappt die sehr menschlich
verändert hat sich nehmen einige von
euch werden lokal kennen und ist doch
wieder heute aussieht und da muss man
einfach mal dass nebenan erhalten okay
ich habe jetzt mal hierhin bild gepackt
von luca wir damals aussah und ihren wir
heute aussieht
dessen vier jahre alte wie kraft kann
sich ein mensch zu kein optisches jahr
ändert ist ja nicht nur die körpergröße
sondern ist einfach über die
zusammensetzung des gesichts epochen
strange weather lukas allerdings kein
weltweites beet haut ein auch vom hocker
ist qualitativ noch besser ich finde
besonders gut wie er da auch betroffen
ist
sie ist deutlich mehr nach ihm heute aus
zwar ist das hier
mir gefällt er besonders gut wie ihr die
haare an dem tag getragen hat wirklich
top stylist damals gab und der
gesichtsausdruck auf dem parkett aus dem
letzten reden genauso aus wie heute zu
sagen hey wir haben die ganzen gesicht
hängt gar nicht verändert euch für luca
damals ganz anders ausgeht ich erst mal
kurz das konkret rede mit dem richtigen
raid blick so checken als nächstes strom
waffe ab gut dass man sich wirklich
sagen er hat auch eine spezielle art
gewinntagen präsentieren das ist nicht
sicher ob ich bin ziemlich mehr cool
oder ich bin mega suite so dass aktuelle
älteste von die verfügbaren zügen welt
ziemlich ziemlich ziemlich genau so wie
heute ist knapp drei jahre alte
traktorfahrer heißt das zweite bild
waren selbstständig auf platz vier muss
ich sagen da zeigen sich schon deutlich
bessere modelqualitäten war auch glaube
ich gar nicht sagen wo er dann endlich
von der agentur angefragt wurde über ihn
zukommen coach und danach sein model job
bekommen hat bei der mega deal aus
musiktherapeuten zugehalten jemand hätte
mit einem schwarzem stift übermalt
im foyer des photoshops bitte sachen
corporate office colombo und sturm hat
einfach vor zwei monaten ungefähr
einfach ein bild von 2011 rausgehauen
alterwürdige stimme erkennen wenn du
heute so gut auf wörter ferien nach
vielen seiner sturm wasser anfällt und
in brus panisch das war 2011 an asterix
über tricks für das richtig stört stellt
auch einen nazi eine stunde durch den
frost weil er gestört viele beiträge
online hat das technische bild von ihm
stammt von 2014 und ist hier erschoss
ein bisschen eingeschüchtert seite so
als würde jemand verstehen und damit
drohen auf seine bühne zu hören
an dem bild ist aber eigentlich nichts
besonderes mehr kennt schon den
grundzügen dass es dieselbe person
überraschung ist nicht vieles wird viel
spannender finde ich von bastl hier
woran denkt ihr wer dieses bild seht
meine erste station ist da ihre oder
daniela negroni ich will jetzt hier gar
nicht noch zuschießen aber das sieht ein
bisschen so aus aber man muss auch
seinen drei jahre her ich war vor drei
jahren auch der richtige missgeburt
heute immer noch kommentar eine sache
einfach of pop in zudem gar nicht haben
kann sind diese girlie profile wo alles
nur show girl ins büro ist mit irgendwie
schön fotografierte messen und schön
fotografiert der mode und alles total
überbelichtet und packt einfach so ab
könnt ihr bitte mal irgendwie halbwegs
authentische instagram profile haben
will ganzes leben auch überbelichtet
schauen wir das nächste mal max an
meinen kleinen bruder der gute hat
immerhin nur 67 beiträge so da kommen
noch halbwegs gut es geht auf dem
ältesten bild in intercitys der gute
mann auch sehr gut getroffen das sieht
so aus als sei von spiegeln im bus
erhältlich ein eigenes handy vor gericht
raul ist nachhaltig zu erkennen wer
häufig sein gesicht erkennen ist dass
die ehre vom 15 juni 2014 und ich würde
sagen ich weiß mein eigener bruder ich
kann das vielleicht nicht ganz so gut
einschätzen wie sich verändert hat im
laufe der zeit aber ich finde sie eins
zu eins auf die heute klarheit bisschen
anders aber so allein von der form des
gesichts her und von der ausstrahlung
hat sich das nur kultur verändert es
immer noch ein richtiger peter schilling
das wird hier nimmt das stammt vom
wittener oktober 2014 sieht effekt schon
das ist so bisschen jünger aussieht als
zeuge als einfach jünger vom gesicht her
aber ich finde das nicht so eine katze
veränderungen über luca das heißt
größten ecke von youtube die sehr
sympathisches die persönlich auch der
korrekte schauen wir doch mal auf die
werte von youtube die richtig abstoßend
ist
ich denke dabei natürlich an rewe plätze
sind für bilder von 23 januar 2017 und
darauf ich nicht mehr zu sehen sondern
auch lena jetzt eingesehen dass durch
älter den das sieht so aus als hätte man
ihn gerade gesagt dass er wegen
steuerhinterziehung angeklagt wird von
riise zwei gesichtshälften würde einfach
vollkommen unabhängig voneinander
unterwegs gerade als nächste anstatt von
26 januar 2014 sieht man das sieht schon
anders aus so sieht schon ganz anders
aus doch felix mit drauf die boj wen
deutlich jünger aus es ist aber auch und
ich sage noch eine ähnliche überfälle
werden nicht wie bei lukas einfach so
die wirkung das gesicht oder die der typ
den mensch abgedichteten drei jahren war
von den kleinen video leute ich bin
dabei meine familie hat mich zum mega
viel zeichnete zu machen deswegen habe
ich das jetzt für euch oder zwischen
gestorben
rechnet man das schwester auf volksfest
hier vielen dank fürs zuschauen soweit
liebe kommt jetzt persönlich vorgetragen
das video und ihr könnt ihm einen kanal
abonnieren
alexa und jetzt bliebe